in most of the
world religions there are forms of
worship and prayer
and celebration which are group
or extroverted in nature they're not
introverted yes
something a ritual or something a ritual
yes
yes i would say wherever there is a deep
archetypal experience which is always
also an emotional experience there is a
spontaneous need
for acting it out and in a way that is a
ritual
and if congenial people are together it
can happen that it becomes a group
ritual that something is done one does
together
but if you organize it the great danger
is that
then people come in who are not in the
congenial mood they are just an annoying
letter before they
at home before they joined or
something or they are just in a sober
mood and not
they are not into it and then it becomes
a formalism
and a dishonest gesture and that's is
the death of all ritual and that
that's what makes religions die that
their
rituals and prayers and gestures always
become mechanical
and done by people who don't feel them
anymore more and more and more
and that's the great danger that's why
you prefer to leave it to the
spontaneous happenings
the hippies meetings where they just
waited for
happenings was close was close to
something real
that was quite good one should be if
anything i would say one should keep it
to such a
in such a form to come sometimes
together and wait for spontaneous
happenings
what about have you ever seen an
american indian dance
the whole village participates and they
have this
long process of preparation as a way i
think maybe of bringing each person into
it
yes i haven't been there but i've read
quite a lot about it and
my impression is that that is really
genuine that's not a formalism that's a
genuine and living expression of an
archetype
but you hear already now that if indian
children had gone to school
and have been indoctrinated by white
man's
nonsense they can't participate anymore
they don't get back into the mood so
that means
as long as you are in it it's all right
but you can't
it's very difficult to find your way
into it again
once you rationalism has thrown you out
yes and that's that's why
i don't know if unions
who are not who come generally from
having had a neurosis and having been
indoctrinated by rational school
education
if they can do it genuinely
i have wondered if there isn't something
for example what happened in
in germany because there was such a
sweeping
over of the culture and a kind of um
falling into yeah ecstasy almost yes
that was a genuine religious phenomenon
but with
in a negative form in a negative form
you see that's a danger when it happens
collectively it generally slips off
into the negative jimmy jones
it slips off into unconsciousness and
letting oneself go into emotion
losing self-control well for instance
those indian dances though
they are ecstatic are highly formally
controlled oh yes
they are highly formed yes and not just
letting out one's emotions and falling
into them
and you see religions have a huge shadow
i mean the islam
who went around and right to the doors
of vienna
beheading everybody who didn't worship
allah
and so on these are these emotional
religions who are just mass movements
and they are not not
necessarily something ideal
they are just the archetypes sweeping
people away
you can see the ones who are in it
enjoyed and the ones who are
out of it pay the bill
if you don't worship allah head off
i remember reading about max zeller's
dream that
he was in working with the inner life he
was
building uh on a temple that would take
hundreds of years to be built and young
called him back after an hour to speak
about this dream
and he said you know how long it will
take for the temple
600 years well that's
image uh is
[Music]
quite a powerful one as if all this
individual work
is building a temple yes i think that's
what i meant when i said before
there are thousands of unions who have
never heard the name yoong
all the people who are honestly working
on their own inner problem in their
own way are builders of a new temple and
it takes 600 years because that means
it takes as long till we are fully in
the aquarian age
and then it will probably come out what
was
building itself up but one must not want
it with one's
mind or head or want to organize it
one must let that happen that's a dream
which would compensate feeling a bit
lonely
feeling a bit an outsider and their
consciousness to him no no
do your own job and you are one of the
builders
hermes prince mingistus said in one
active imagination to an alchemist i am
the friend of whoever is lonely
unconscious doesn't speak to you when
you are with people your attention goes
to the people
well when you are lonely i have lived in
this tower sometimes three weeks alone
without
speaking to one word to anybody and i
sometimes thought i was going off my
head
but the unconscious became alive it was
my partner
and that's why you have to be lonely so
that the unconscious becomes
stronger you it's like loading up the
unconscious and then
it manifests and then you are not lonely
anymore
so we have to support the unconscious
it's not enough to to just have it we
have to
actively turn towards it and support it
so that it then
helps us